vas-y dépasse moi ça peut se faire
plaisir
c'est pas trop des vacances il ya le
couple qui veut acheter qui revient la
fin du mois pour la contre-visite c'est
important tu prends celui ci ont dû bien
ok et toujours vous ai frôlé les mômes
là ce serait plus prudent vous
apprennent les bons réflexes les bonnes
positions
moi je pourrais tu apprendras trazié
c'est l'oeuf devant les invités partis
partenaires je crois bien cherché
salaires - sagbo jack black c'est
bizarre mais c'est à la gauche ouais
c'est le gsp
c'est un très bel homme les yeux doux
j'appelle la facile
et les races et mon box non non c'est le
prénom de ma mère ouais c'est jalouse ça
y est vue mais ça fait mille ans que ça
choque plus personne que les hommes sont
avec des djeuns mais nous les femmes
embrasse cacher j'ai envie de faire du
mal mais ni papier ni se projeter très
sympa mais c'était une histoire sa 21e
siècle ça ça peut être des baskets mais
touchante mais bon là indycar qui pour
une fois que tu es pas maltraités et
comptait ne serait vraiment dommage de
laisser un homme te faire du bien
on doit penser qu'on ait découvert en
fait j'aime pas des couleurs plutôt des
mails mother i'd like to fuck
[Musique]
oh
aussi alors vous êtes en rétention de
familles comme vous apercevoir avec
votre fils la presby sans toi allez on
s'en va mal